[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy president Trump's so-called
Muslim ban the focus of so much leftist
hysteria is dead for the time being
after the hard-left 9th Circuit Court of
Appeal Struck it down what is noteworthy
however in their ruling is that the
ruling never even mentions once the
relevant law by which Trump claims the
authority to limit immigration in the
first place here is that law suspension
of Entry or imposition of restrictions
by President whenever the president
finds that the entry of any aliens or of
any class of aliens into the United
States would be detrimental to the
interests of the United States he may by
proclamation and for such period as he
shall deem necessary suspend the entry
of all aliens or any class of aliens as
immigrants or non-immigrants or impose
on the entry of aliens any restrictions
he may deem to be
appropriate now despite the fact that
the appeals court simply ignored this
law it is the core of the whole
controversy it's hard to see how any
presidential action restricting
immigration can be overruled in light of
this law as it specifies that whenever
the president finds that the entry of
any aliens or of any class of aliens
into the United States would be
detrimental to the interests of the
United States he can suspend the entry
of all aliens or any class of aliens now
president Trump knows this and that's
why right after the ninth circuit came
down with its judge with with its ruling
he tweeted lawfare remarkably in the
entire opinion the panel did not bother
even to cite this statute a disgraceful
decision now the quote within the
president's tweet came from Benjamin
witties of the Brookings Institution who
also noted in an article on the ruling
that on the vital question of the ban
being necessary for National Security
the decision spends only one sentence
and one brief footnote witties however
took issue with Trump's quoting him to
support his opposition to the ruling and
tweeted you decide whether the podus is
quoting me in context here's the article
for the record I support the decision
very well let's decide in the first
place his affiliation with the Brookings
institution calls his motives into
question as Brookings funding from qar
has turned it into an apologist for
Jihad Terror with Jihadi preachers and
Islamic supremacists frequently featured
and lauded at its events including Sheik
yusf Al karwi the internationally
renowned Muslim preacher who has praised
Hitler and expressed the hope that
Muslims would finish his work of killing
Jews second whitties notes that the
decision omitted all discussion of the
relevant law but then brushes that aside
not on legal grounds but on pragmatic
grounds he says the ninth circuit is
correct to to leave the temporary
restraining order in place in my view
for the simple reason that there is no
cause to plunge the country into turmoil
again while the courts address the
merits of these matters over the next
few weeks he also opposes Trump's
executive order because he attributes
malign motives to the president himself
referring to quote incompetent
malevolence with which this order was
promulgated now it's arguable that it
was incompetent but malevolent president
Trump and everyone around him has been
consistent this ban is from first to
last about National Security for the
left apparently now even any concern for
National Security is inherently
malevolent shortly before the appeals
court ruling the Trump's Trump
Administration released a list of
terrorism cases involving suspects from
the seven countries included in his
temporary suspension of immigration
Somalia Sudan Iraq Iran Yemen Syria and
Libya the list gave the lie to the claim
of Judge James robart of the US District
Court for the Western District of
Washington state who ruled against
Trump's ban earlier robart had claimed
that no one from the seven countries on
the ban list had been involved in Terror
activity inside the United States
robarts false claim and the bizarre
omission of the ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals shows that the opponents of
Trump's plan to restrict immigration in
the name of National Security care about
as much about the facts as they care
about protecting Americans these nakedly
political rulings should not and must
not stand both for national security
reasons and for the health and Sanity of
our judicial system going forward I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]